>> Neil: WE WILL CONTINUE
MONITORING THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE, A VIRTUAL ONE.
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM WHERE THEY
ARE RE-IMPOSING RESTRICTIONS AND
A SO-CALLED HOT ZONE WHERE
HOSPITAL CAPACITY HAS GOTTEN
VERY LOW.
IT’S A NEW METRIC USED TO
JUSTIFY CURBING --
PRETTY SWEEPING MEASURES.
A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS ALREADY
UPSET WITH THE STRONG ARM IN A
VERY INTRUSIVE GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS HOW MANY CRITICS SEE
THIS.
OTHERS SEE THE GOVERNOR SIMPLY
TRYING TO PROTECT HIS FOLKS.
I WILL LIKELY BE ADDED INTO THIS
YEAR, BUT THEY’RE CRACKED DOWN
THERE WHILE NOT A LOCKDOWN WILL
HAVE RULING SORT OF RESTRICTIONS
HERE THAT WILL NO DOUBT ROIL THE
STATE FOR THE NEXT THREE WEEKS
TO COME.
A FELLOW WHO KNOWS THE PROCESS
QUITE WELL, THE GOVERNOR OF OHIO
WHO AMONG OTHER THINGS ADDED HIS
STATE ITSELF TO A TRAVEL WARNING
LIST.
GOVERNOR, VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
WHAT IS THIS TRAVEL RESTRICTION
ADVICE YOU ARE GIVING RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, WHAT WE HAVE ALWAYS
DONE IS PUT A MAP UP EVERY
WEDNESDAY FOR THE PEOPLE OF OHIO
AND PUT THE POSITIVITY RATES OF
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ADD 15% POSITIVITY IS VERY HIGH.
AND THAT IS A WARNING.
WHAT WE HAD TO DO TODAY TO BE
CONSISTENT AND HONEST IS TO SAY,
OHIO IS AT 15% NOW.
WE WANT PEOPLE -- ONE MORE
CAUTION.
IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN A LIGHT THAT
GOES ON AND SAYS IF YOU ARE
GOING TO THIS DATE, BE CAREFUL,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A VERY HIGH
SPREAD OF THE INFECTION.
NOW, WE HAVE A VARIED HIGH
WE HAVE TO TELL OUR OWN CITIZENS
THAT.
>> Neil: IT DOESN’T EVEN GO
DOWN WELL WITH MEMBERS OF YOUR
OWN PARTY, GOVERNOR.
YOU ARE GOING TOO FAR WITH THESE
ORDERS.
WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> FOUR MEMBERS IN THE GENERAL
ASSEMBLY, AND FOUR OF THEM THINK
I SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO THINK
THAT, BUT I’M GOING ON ABOUT MY
BUSINESS AND, YOU KNOW, FOCUSED
ON WHAT WE HAVE TO GET DONE BOTH
WITH COVID RELATED AND FRANKLY
WITH OTHER THINGS.
WE HAVE A BUDGET COMING UP, AND
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS.
THE LEGISLATURE IS IN A LAME
DUCK SESSION RIGHT NOW.
I’M WORKING WITH THE SENATOR AND
THE TWO LEADERS.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE WORKING THINGS
THROUGH.
>> YOU KNOW, ALL THIS OCCURS
THAT POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT IS A
SHARED WHILE YOU HAD SAID NOT
TOO LONG AGO THAT THE PRESIDENT
WILL CERTAINLY WELL WITHIN HIS
RIGHT TO, YOU KNOW, GET TAKEOUT
RIGHT AND MAKE SURE IT WAS
RIGHT.
AT THAT AS YOU SAW THINGS BACK
LAST TIME WE CHATTED, IT LOOKED
LIKE JOE BIDEN WAS GOING TO
EMERGE AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ON JANUARY 20TH AT
NEXT YEAR.
DO YOU STILL SUBSCRIBE TO THAT?
>> YEAH, BOTH.
I JUST LISTENED TO YOUR ACCOUNT.
I THINK IT IS GREAT.
NO ONE SHOULD BE FEARFUL OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OR ANYONE GOING INTO COURT AND
PUTTING FORTH EVIDENCE -- HE HAS
EVERY RIGHT TO DO THAT.
COURTS ARE GREAT.
FINDERS OF FACT.
AND THE COURTS ARE OPEN, AND
PEOPLE HAVE ABSOLUTELY EVERY
RIGHT TO USE THEM INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I ALSO SAID THAT IT IS CERTAINLY
APPEARED THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
GOING TO BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
I HAVE HAD A VERY GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I WAS TALKING TO HIM LAST NIGHT
ABOUT OHIO-RELATED MATTER THAT I
DIDN’T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
COVID.
WHENEVER I HAVE ASKED HIM, I’VE
CALLED HIM.
IT YOU KNOW, HE HAS BEEN THERE
AND DONE EVERYTHING HE COULD TO
HELP US THROUGH THIS VIRUS.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, THE GOOD
NEWS -- WHEN I TALK TO PEOPLE OF
OHIO AND DID A PRESS CONFERENCE
TODAY, YOU KNOW, WE’VE TALKED
ABOUT WAS THE GOOD NEWS?
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
VACCINE IS COMING.
>> Neil: DID THE CONVERSATION
EVER OF THE YEAR, WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING TO HIM LAST NIGHT, YOU
KNOW, HE HAD SUGGESTED MAY BE
PRIMARIING YOU BECAUSE OF YOUR
COMMENTS LIKE JOE BIDEN WAS
GOING TO BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
IT DID NOT COME UP?
>> WE DIDN’T GET INTO THAT.
WE TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW, A
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAD IN OHIO,
SOMETHING THAT I WANTED THEIR
HELP ON.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WOULD SEE
WHAT HE CAN DO AND HE ALWAYS
DOES THAT.
LOOK, IT’S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
THAT RELATIONSHIP.
AND I WAS PROUD TO BE HE IS
CHAIRMAN IN OHIO.
AND WE WON BY EIGHT POINTS.
>> Neil: ON RIGHT, NOT TOO
SHABBY.
LET ME ASK YOU A LITTLE THEN ON
THIS IF YOU DON’T MIND, SIR.
BILL BARR HAD MUCH SIMILAR THING
IS SAY ABOUT THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
FRAUD AND BIG ELECTIONS AND HAS
NO DOUBT THAT MAY BE SOME OF
THAT WAS GOING ON.
DO YOUR POINT, NOT TO THE DEGREE
THAT IT WOULD IT CHANGE THE
OUTCOME.
APPARENTLY THE PRESIDENT
BRISTLED AT THAT THAT.
THERE IS REPORTS THAT HE MIGHT
FIRE OR CONSIDER GETTING RID OF
THE GENERAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
YOU THINK THAT WOULD BE
ADVISABLE FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
FIRE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL?
>> I REMEMBER SOMETHING
PRESIDENT BUSH ONCE SAID.
HE HAD A MEMBER OF HIS STAFF
THAT WAS DOING SOMETHING AND
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING.
AND SOME OTHER MEMBER OF
CONGRESS -- I DON’T KNOW.
AT THE PRESIDENT SAID, YOU KNOW,
YOU NEED TO STAY IN YOUR LANE.
MY LANE IS TO FOCUS ON OHIO AND
TO FOCUS ON THIS VIRUS.
YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW THE FACTS
THAT YOU ARE RECOUNTING.
FRANKLY, I HAVE BEEN FOCUS THE
LAST FEW DAYS ON GETTING THE
VACCINE.
AND WHEN I WAS ABOUT TO SAY A
MINUTE AGO IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS A MAJOR ACCOMPLISHMENT
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
AND IT’S COMING, AND IT’S
COMING, YOU THINK, AROUND
DECEMBER 15TH, WE ARE GOING TO
BE PUTTING SHOTS IN PEOPLE’S
ARMS IN OHIO HOPEFULLY THE NEXT
DAY APPEARED WE ARE EXCITED
ABOUT IT.
I THINK IT IS A MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Neil: GOVERNOR, BEFORE I
LEAVE YOU, WE ARE GOING LIVE FOR
THIS IN ABOUT A HEARING WHERE
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO OUTLINE
EXACTLY THE ABUSES THAT IT SEES
THAT COST THAT NOT ONLY IN THAT
STATE, IT COST THE PRESIDENT A
WIN IN THAT STATEMENT SOME OF
THESE OTHER BATTLEGROUND STATES.
SUMMIT SAID THAT THIS BATTLE
WILL BE ONLY RESOLVED WHEN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE MEETS IN LESS
THAN TWO WEEKS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS INDICATED
THAT IF THAT IS THE POINT AT
WHICH JOE BIDEN WINS, WHATEVER
HIS GRIEVANCES, HE WILL ACCEPT
THAT.
BUT OTHERS AREN’T SO SURE.
DO YOU THINK THAT WHEN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE GATHERS AND
CONFIRMS AND CERTIFIES THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS WON, THAT IT IS
OVER, THAT THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
BE GRACIOUS, THAT HE SHOULD
ATTEND THE INAUGURATION, WHAT?
>> SURE.
LOOK, THAT IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
YOU JUST QUOTED THE PRESIDENT AS
SAYING THAT IS WHAT HE WOULD DO.
YOU KNOW, I TAKE AIM AT HIS WORD
AND THAT HE WILL DO THAT.
>> Neil: HE DIDN’T SAY HE
WOULD GO TO THE INAUGURATION --
>> [LAUGHS]
WELL, LOOK --
WE HAVE A GREAT TRADITION IN
THIS COUNTRY FOR 200 YEARS.
AND PEOPLE EXCEPT THE RESULT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
GO INTO COURT.
THE LOSER ALWAYS ACCEPTS IT.
AND WE MOVE ON.
IT DOESN’T MEAN THAT WE LIKE IT,
YOU KNOW.
IT IS ACCEPT IT, BECAUSE THAT IS
PART OF WHO WE ARE.
THAT IS WHAT MAKES US DIFFERENT
THAN A LOT OF PLACES ON EARTH.